[Applauso]
lo spazio lo spazio enorme lo spazio per
definizione qualcosa di grande e
silenzioso
e statico e inodore e lo spazio
questa bene quello che pensiamo quando
siamo piccoli io la pensavo così ma
penso tutti noi la pensavamo così
da bambini che ama la nostra enorme la
cameretta che merita sia una cosa
grandissima quando siamo piccoli poi
cresciamo ci accorgiamo che questo
spazio tanto grande e non è più se poi
se poi vogliamo parlare della sala ciao
nella sala possiamo giocare a pallone
possiamo andare in bicicletta di mamma e
di solito non sono molto contente
all'idea che noi si vada in bicicletta
però per noi c'è tantissimo spazio e
anche le mamme sono grandissime quando
siamo piccoli
poi pian pianino si cresce siamo noi che
cresciamo gli spazi rimangono quelli ma
siamo noi che cresciamo
e piano piano ci rendiamo conto che la
nostra cameretta la nostra sala casa
nostra non ci bastano più abbiamo tutto
lo spazio del mondo da conquistare e li
dobbiamo soltanto essere abbastanza
coraggiosi e abbastanza spavaldi da
conquistarlo per me era al volo per me è
il volo per me era diventare pilota e
paracadutista e quindi tutta la strada
in quella direzione e lo spazio orali
rimaneva grande rimanere immenso
rimaneva silenzioso rimaneva inodore
e quindi diventi pilota diventi
paracadutista diventi un giovane uomo
comincia a crescere
piano piano ti rendi conto del fatto che
quello spazio ti appartiene che non fai
fatica a conquistarla giorno dopo giorno
diventa sempre un pochino più tuo
finché un giorno me l'hanno spoilerata
ma è decisamente una pessima giornata
ed è un attimo è un attimo con lo spazio
enorme quello spazio silenzioso stati
confermo ti si chiude addosso diventa
tutto piccolo ti trovi chiuso nel volume
di un letto ma ti chiudi travi chiuso
dentro un corpetto di teflon
ma ancora di più titolari chiuso dentro
un corpo che non riconosci più un corpo
che non ti riconosce più un corpo che
non vuoi un corpo che non ti vuole
allora ti sembra veramente che sia tutto
finito che quello spazio enorme non
esiste
non è così lo spazio lo gestiamo noi lo
spazio non ci stiamo noi con la nostra
testa è la nostra forza mentale il
nostro cuore che ci permettono di
gestire lo spazio io sono stato
fortunatissimo io ho avuto una mamma che
è stata la mamma super e delle sorelle
super e una famiglia super e degli
affetti super che mi hanno aiutato a
fare quel click per cercare di crearmi
degli spazi diversi
allora è stato quello che all'inizio con
i gomiti
ho cercato nuovi spazi aveva cominciato
all'inizio con una palestra giocando a
basket
è già la più grande di un letto tanta
roba rispetto a un letto e lì ci si
muoveva bene
e trovarvi i tuoi spazi come atleta me
li davano volentieri gli spazi perché
giocavo malissimo per cui mi facevano
andare dove volevo su quel campo tanto
dentro la mettevo
dopo un po però quello spazio cominciato
a diventare piccolo ma lo spazio era
quello
questa volta non era lo spazio che mi si
era chiuso addosso
era il rio che in qualche modo e volevo
e non mi bastavano più quegli spazi
e allora comincia ad affacciarmi a
quello che poi è diventato lo sport più
bello per me lo sci anni di gare anni di
montagna a me di allenamento anni in cui
lo spazio che diventa grandissimo tu sei
piccolino quando va in montagna quando
chiunque di noi va in montagna è
piccolino perché la natura è immensa la
natura è grandissima
e poi ci si ritrova a un certo punto con
questo spazio che però continua non
bastardi perché si è vero si stai
volando ma ti trovi in una condizione
scusate se in uno spazio grande massa
una condizione per la quale ti manca
quello che è reti manca il volo per me
era il volo nello spazio per me è il
volo è il mio spazio
è il problema era soltanto quello che mi
trovavo a fare qualcosa come hobby che a
un certo punto non mi bastava più non mi
piaceva più lavoravo in banca un bel
mestiere sicuramente un gran mestiere un
mestiere sicuro ma mi mancavano gli
spazi mi mancavano i miei spazi e allora
decisi di spostarmi e andai egitto
andare a vivere in egitto per qualche
anno dove l'avrai come videoperatore
subacquea in carrozzina come
videoperatore subacquee gli spazi ci
sono anche gli spazi ci sono io vivevo
in sinai nel deserto del sinai e di
giorno facevo il video operatore
subacqueo
se pensiamo e l'abbiamo imparato sui
libri di scuola che 70 per cento del
mondo è fatto di acqua il fatto di
lavorare sott'acqua beh non mi potevo
lamentare nello spazio allo spazio lo
avevo di sicuro però anche lì a un certo
punto ci si trova nella condizione per
cui lo spazio non ti basta più perché
sono cambiate le tue condizioni è
cambiata la situazione sociale è
cambiato quello che volevi o comunque
sta semplicemente facendo qualcosa per
cui ti sei adattato e allora dopo un po
non ti bastano più gli spazi e quello
che ti serve per fare quel click in più
viene sempre dalla testa e dal cuore ed
è lì che a un certo punto prendi e
decidi di fare un passo in più di
metterti in gioco e allora parto per gli
stati uniti negli stati uniti si poteva
volare i paraplegici potevano già a
volare un taglio era una cosa che
avevamo provato a fare con quegli aerei
che avevate visto prima prima con gli
arcani ultraleggeri ma non ne potevo
farne una professione
allora mi trasferì negli stati uniti
rimasi lì per qualche anno
feci delle esperienze bellissime e lì lo
spazio era enorme grandissimo ali era e
piano piano
avevo cominciato a crederci
avevo ricominciato a crescere anche lo
spazio fosse grande che lo spazio fosse
fermo nello spazio fosse silenzioso e
inodore e poi un giorno ti si chiude
addosso un giorno va dal medico e ti
rendi conto che tenuta fuori un'altra
magagna perché le prossime giornate ogni
tanto si ripetono che ti trovi che non
puoi più volare per un po ti trovi che
tutto quello su cui avevi lavorato non
funziona
ti trovi che devi mollare non vuole
mollare non ce la fai perché lo spazio
ti sta veramente chiudendo perché questa
volta se non eletto perché questa volta
gli odori li senti sono gli odori degli
ospedali i rumori di senti perché non è
vero che silenzioso sono i campanelli
sono le parole e le voci degli altri
pazienti sono gli infermieri che sono
meravigliosi ma la mattina parlano
sempre a voce alta
è vero
e allora cerchi ancora di rifarti di
spazio e questa volta te lo fai con
calma non più a gomitate ma con un
sorriso cercando di trovare un po di
serenità serenità per la quale spesso
gli anni aiutano sicuramente gli anni
aiutano un po allora decide di
continuare
a facendo dire qualcosa di completamente
diverso
il cane io adoro il cane i cani sono
degli animali fantastici e allora decido
di farmi un po di spazio come
addestratore cinofilo
contatto una scuola per addestratori un
centro cinofilo di torino persone
veramente splendide alle quali chiedo ma
secondo io posso fare addestratore di
cani li conosco da tanti anni ho sempre
avuto cani
allora facciamo questo corso insieme
facciamo questo corso corso lungo e
diventa addestratore cinofilo del volo
quasi mai di me proporre mi si apre
questa volta al cuore mi si apre
sono tornato a fare qualcosa che mi
piaceva
e siccome lo spazio è contagioso perché
lo spazio è contagioso quando voi siete
aperti mentalmente al mondo quando voi
aprite il vostro cuore al mondo
le altre persone si aprono verso di voi
e auto blu quindi assolutamente in modo
completamente inaspettato ne arriva una
chiamata mi arriva una telefonata da
verona nella quale mi dicono che stanno
cercando un istruttore per cercare di
cambiare il modo in cui sta lavorando la
scuola dell'aeroclub di verona
non mi sembrava vero
mollo i cani non mollo il mio cane è ma
mollo e cane e mi della spedisco verona
e lì cominciò a lavorare con persone
splendide con le quali cominciano a
provare i progetti
e sono tornato a volare gli spazi sono
grandi e gli spazi sono veramente grandi
e siccome come ho detto lo spazio è
contagioso vengo contattato da dei
vecchi amici francesi e svizzeri che
avevo frequentato anni prima persone con
lo stesso con la stessa passione che mi
propongono di partecipare a un progetto
che si chiamava che si chiama andy
flight brown the world and if lente è
un'organizzazione che portava a livello
internazionale così come i baroni rotti
in italia il volo per le persone
disabili
ma questa volta volevamo portare un
messaggio il messaggio che volevamo
portare ero messaggio di inclusione in
tutti i paesi del mondo e allora il volo
comincia dalla svizzera italia per
arrivare in egitto arabia saudita io ho
preso i comandi in thailandia e in
thailandia presione aeroplano quello
piccolino che avete visto prima con il
quale ho volato su posti bellissimi ho
volato sui mari perché dalla thailandia
sono arrivato a singapore indonesia dall
indonesia sono arrivata in australia
e lì gli spazi erano grandi erano spazi
mentali era tutto aperto
ma soprattutto la cosa più bella era
condiviso
perché era quello di far vedere in paesi
dove la disabilità non viene a perno non
viene vissuta come
una situazione che merita inclusione ma
spesso come una situazione che porta un
po di vergogna nel contesto sociale
nella quale si sviluppa a cercare di far
vedere che si può fare
poi tornò in italia
ricomincia a volare
ricomincio persona scuola di volo e un
amico un caro amico mi chiede di andare
a fare un giro con suo aeroplano bella
romano è bellissimo e quella teoria che
ormai avevo un pò imparato del fatto che
lo spazio non fosse una cosa statica
mela era un po dimenticata onestamente
mela sono ricordato quel giorno non si
libera dal 17 maggio del 2019 quando
tornando verso l'aeroporto
lì è diventato veramente silenzioso
perché a rumore della romano ha smesso
di esserci perché il motore si è spento
perché lui era il pilota ma ho dovuto
prendere i comandi per un attimo e ho
visto che in aeroporto non ci arrivavo
la valpolicella stupenda è piena di
vigne non c'è un posto dove mettere un
aeroplano
c'è un campo là in fondo ma se lo
sbaglio prendo una casa facciamo un
disastro quindi l'unico posto il fiume
prendiamo l'aeroplano lo configura per
andare verso il fiume
arriviamo del fiume ammar chiamo nel
fiume
il film comincia a entrare piano piano a
livello dell'acqua sale lo sgancio la
mia cintura lo sgancio al centro di
daniele daniele riesce ad uscire nel
frattempo però
l'aeroplano viene viene
sommerso dall'acqua viene girato
dall'acqua io sono completamente sotto
gli di spazio ragazzi non ce n'è più
cominciamo proprio più comincia a bere
un po d'acqua ma per fortuna avevo
lavorato in egitto per tanti anni ero
comunque un sommozzatore esperto e avevo
imparato che bere un po d'acqua non è la
fine del mondo sono si può gestire un po
d'acqua
morale della favola ne venga fuori con
un posto rotto con due gambe rotte ma
con un braccio riesco ad uscire dalla
romano riesco a nuotare verso la riva e
mi aiuta daniele ad arrivare verso la
verdoliva mi faccio qualche mese di
ospedale ria giusto le ossa
e torno a fare quello che facevo prima
torno
a insegnare alle persone a volare torno
a vivere il mio spazio
e ancora siccome quando poi siamo aperti
mentalmente le cose succedono ricevo una
telefonata
sono al bar dell'aeroporto e ricevo una
telefonata pronto buongiorno sono un
funzionario del quirinale ora
onestamente
è
ok anch'io ho pensato fosse una presa in
giro ho letto una televendita non è
perché non arriva laverty gestion del
quirinale il numero e 106 corto vuoi
vedere che questi sono davvero dal
quirinale e mi dicono guardi siano poco
belli il presidente mattarella il signor
presidente mattarella ha sentito della
sua storia ma soprattutto del lavoro che
lei ha fatto per l'integrazione delle
persone disabili in aviazione e vorrebbe
conferirle un premio o quantomeno
l'onore efficienza con un ufficiale
all'ordine della repubblica italiana
allora vengo invitato al quirinale
grazie dove ricevo dove ricevo questa
onoreficenza un
prestigio e norme un orgoglio
grandissimo una felicità che non si può
descrivere
ed esco dal palazzo del quirinale che
tra l'altro è bellissimo posto stupendo
e torno a fare il mio ritorno a farlo
circondato da quelle persone che mi
hanno accolto la prima volta e ritorno
ad avere quello spazio grande che alla
fine è quello che mi appartiene
dove vivo io dove vivo quei mi ero plani
dove sto per aria dove riesco a
trasmettere alle persone quella che è la
mia passione
questo non basta però perché ormai la
lezione l'ha imparata
lo spazio si può chiudere e si può
riaprire quando si chiude non lo puoi
decidere una mattina per un motivo per
l'altro che si chiude addosso
quello che puoi fare tu e gestire il
dopo e vedere come venirne fuori
ed è allora io sono dell'idea che con
l'energia e l'energia è data dalla testa
e dal cuore si riesce ad avere la forza
di ricrearsi lo spazio e di ricominciare
con un sorriso e con tanta grinta a
gestire questo spazio grazie
[Applauso]